sans doute
l'avion privé le plus luxueux voudront
du monde des snacks big ben ali
traduisez grand lapin et nous vous y
trompez pas l'heure mais c'est surtout
grâce aux balises ferment d'une fille
souvent clavier il faut que les pages de
playboy hugh hefner a bâti son emploi il
avait 3000 francs 1952 il possède
aujourd'hui plus de 600 millions de
francs non répartis dans l'édition les
clubs les complexes touristiques la
décoration et la mode
la télévision est aujourd'hui le cinéma
puisqu'il va financer le film que roman
polanski qui l'accompagnent mettra en
scène macbeth d'après shakespeare
armani gucci unification c'est le
contraire et nadine qui squattent
peut-être je vais traduire le personnage
à ma droite
non
à l'enseigné vous petit lapin voici les
hôtesses qui l'accompagnent d'équilibré
de lui dans ce palace poulain
là
avec un tel appareil
n'avez vous jamais tenté les pirates de
l'air ont ils jamais tenté un
détournement en vol non pas encore mais
ça pourrait bien m'arriver
on dit que vous avez beaucoup d'argent
c'est une question oui j'aime beaucoup
l'art
à